chaos chaos the word it's amazing how
many entrepreneurs don't make it in
business or survive simply because they
don't know how to handle chaos believe
me this is something that was very
difficult for me initially when I was an
entrepreneur but let me tell you what's
going on right on my life what you see
behind me is a moving truck in the last
seven days this is what's happened last
seven days I'm currently in California
we are moving our entire family to
Dallas Texas so the house right behind
me we bought a house in Dallas Texas
we're moving the office we're moving all
of our staffs a stuff from their house
the things we had to move from the
office yesterday till one o'clock in the
morning every single thing taking place
here they have to go to all their homes
and move their things we had a
convention that took place last week
four-day convention with speaker line-up
of you know Al Unser jr. Robert green
Joe Jordan Grant Cardone and it started
from 8 o'clock in the morning went till
midnight 4 days straight then on the
last step we had to surprise some of our
leaders and had to have all the things
be in place with nine exotic cars then
on Monday night we flew back our East
Coast people came with me I took them to
a Laker event with Shaq and Jeannie bus
and you know when Dan got a private tour
the locker room and had dinner and shot
around at the regular you know court of
the Lakers it was phenomenal time my
wife's pregnant five months I got two
boys I got my nanny families over here
dealing with the real estate sale here
all of these things are taking place all
of these things are taking place and so
someone asked how do you handle what all
these things take in place and how do
you handle all these chaos I said it's a
perfect episode to put together because
the question gets asked quite often and
how does somebody improve so today I'm
gonna talk about three things with chaos
one the big four of chaos four types of
chaos - three types of people and how to
respond to chaos and seven tips on how
you can become at handling kills let's
start off with this first a big four
first a big four there are four types of
chaos and believe it or not they're all
connected to each other one is not
separate than the other one first you
have your personal life family you got
breakups
that's the chaos some don't know how to
handle breakups and it leaks into their
business life divorce happens two out of
three marriages nowadays end up at a
divorce it's something that's happening
death how you handle death in the family
it's gonna happen we're all only here
for about 70 80 90 years so how do you
handle that then you have children
children that are going through their
own breakups going they're getting sick
they these are all small kills that are
taking place some of you are having a
hard time watching this video because
it's sound you're hearing around you
that's chaotic to you right so now next
financial that's chaos debt expenses
wedding how do I handle my meeting oh my
god I got a wedding I have people always
tell me I have this wedding I need to
prepare it's 90 days out and morning
till night everything gets affected
because there's a wedding day in a
wedding there's only six seven eight
hours but they take 90 days it becomes
chaotic in their lives
income new house they're buying I have
to move in to have to do this they have
to do that everything goes on shut down
for about 90 days when there's a house
because to them that's chaotic right
health your weight weight goes up energy
low it's chaotic everything else is
affected by it
illness you get sick you're you know you
you you prolong your sickness because
you don't take care of yourself you
don't know how to get to work when I'm
sick I can't work I don't feel good I
don't go to the office lost have a loved
one your diet it's chaotic as the way
you handle yourself your energy is low
you're injuring you broke something your
voice my voice how long ago was it when
my voice what happened to this was your
your and a half ago two years ago all of
a sudden my voice was gone so I go to
the doctor we're going ever I just can't
do videos if you go back and watch some
of my old videos you'll hear my voice is
completely gone so I couldn't project
and my business's voice right and we
went to the doctor multiple doctors and
they say this could be cancer this could
be cancer this could be cancer and then
all of a sudden had to do surgery my
voice was gone purely for a month one
month they had no voice and we found out
the good news was it was benign and it's
right before Thanksgiving when the
surgery was done this is the first time
ever in my life and Thanksgiving we're
having dinner I can't say anything to
anybody I mean maybe it was God's we
have seen you to be quiet for about a
month but the point being it was chaotic
so that's hell then you have business
your your chaos could be what vendor you
don't hit a deadline it's chaotic you
have a deadline it's coming up this
Friday we have to deliver a client
doesn't like you there was a
confrontation one of your agents or rep
or an employee didn't treat a client
well staff confrontation some staff
wants a raise you can't give it to him
you don't want to give it to them you
know there's problems there too
staff members and work it together a
business partner doesn't do as much as
you want them to do you feel like you do
more than they do technology is not
going well your IT guys are not doing
their part behind the scenes they're
working slow it keeps giving you too
many glitches there's complaints you
launch it's not good launch
that's chaotic then you have your sales
guys are not hitting their numbers goals
are not being hit your investor is doing
too many conference call on you're
hitting your number so what's going on
with this too much pressure and it's not
from a different point of view you're
financing the market conditions are bad
economic conditions are bad you having a
lot of problems with that you have
competition is giving you a hard time
your reputation online reputation
you got your regulations new laws you
have a lawsuit all that stuff's taking
place that is all chaotic this is going
to happen when you're running the
business it's all chaotic so what can we
do about this by the way most of the
time the way you handle these three will
automatically affect this if you don't
know how to handle these three this is
always going to take a hit because one
of these things are always going to
happen our lives no matter what we do so
how do we make sure we handle this to
make sure we're leading this can it
really be done of course it can many
have done it so let's talk about three
types of ways people handle chaos hang
on let's talk about three types of ways
people handle chaos so first one is
first one is amateurs amateurs tend to
overlap all day long cut the video all
day freakin long we asked you to do one
thing right you can't even move nothing
it doesn't matter we're doing a damn
video over here man what the cut the
damn video all day long he does this
crap something
that's called overreacting that's what
you don't do right so we wanted to get
your intention you get the idea there
are people Mario we love you Mario come
back your buddy okay amateurs tend to
overreact amateurs tend to over react um
back to me got your attention they
overreact some like that happens in
their business all day long they're
overreacting to the issue they panic
they quit
that's what amateurs do amateurs do that
right that was just the behavior of an
amateur next intermediate they give the
chaos too much attention it doesn't need
that much attention meaning it's not as
big as they think it is they slow down
they use it as an alibi to get in the
way of getting to the next level let me
explain to what I mean by this
intermediate so a lot of times believe
it or not people like to create chaos in
their lives here's why if they create
chaos in their lives they can always use
that as an alibi why this is why I could
never make it as an entrepreneur it
gives them an out it gives them a reason
to talk amongst their peers and say the
reason why didn't make it as a real
estate agent is because of X Y Z the
reason why to make it as an insurance is
because if expert the reason why could
make it as an entrepreneur is this the
reason why they they love this alibi
then the highest one is expert what
experts do is they anticipate it what
experts do is they're not afraid to ask
for help what experts do is they process
issues quickly they process issues
quickly anticipate there's nothing like
knowing there's going to be problems
there's nothing like knowing I'm going
to ask for help to see if somebody else
knows how to help me get this thing done
and last but not least process issues
quickly so if there's an issue let's
address it quickly let's solve it and
let's move on so now seven tips seven
tips seven tips on how to handle chaos
like a pro number one it's all
perspective let me tell you what's
perspective so you may be in a problem
and chaotic time and everybody is
overreacting it's your job as a leader
to give perspective to everybody so for
instance the other day
somebody told me what they told me and
everybody was oh my goodness what are we
gonna do with this what are we gonna do
with that said listen to me while we're
here having a saw this business problem
there is bombs and rockets and all this
stuff taking place in the Middle East
believe me it's not that big of a deal
but let's handle it let's get to it
everybody got calmed down everybody did
it's not as a big deal somebody needs to
always put perspective and give
gratitude the other one mole hill into a
mountain
someone needs to not turn a molehill
into a mountain there are issues that
are very critical that needs to be
solved right away but someone needs to
say this is not a big deal let's get it
fixed is it really
chaos just because some happen your
business you can't Tyler that's chaos it
just could be a smaller issue you need
to fix so you need to make you don't
need to make it bigger than it really is
to seek wise counsel it's what you need
to do when there's chaotic times in your
life marriage business finance health
gets get get with get wise counsel go to
a doctor go to a financial advisor go to
somebody who has been in your
relationship in your position before
personal life or parenting and have
someone like that give you counsel if
there's business talk to your attorney
talk to your CPA talk to your mentor let
them give you some feedback 3 focus on
what you can control not what you can't
control
if something's going on in the
government or you know a law got passed
or new regulation got passed or sums
happened with the economy you can't do
nothing about that
you just have to do how can I control
this what can I do with what I can
control let's go work with it and employ
some happens to their life personal life
it's a extremely big thing because a
very important employee you need to be
able to control what you can control you
can't control everything you move on for
over prepare yourself and your team it's
extremely important to be over preparing
yourself and your team 5 come up with
the next three steps on what you need to
be doing come up with the next three
steps on what you need to be doing
always come up with one two three six
study the birth of the chaotic situation
what I mean by them always find out who
gave birth to the chaos meaning if
there's a trend of the same person who
keeps giving birth to the chaos you
to fire that person or get rid of that
person or there needs to be something
being solved here because they're giving
birth to all the chaos and the last one
is don't take it personal
chaos are part of business part of life
it's gonna happen none of us are free
from it how you react to it will dictate
how much you advance in life as an
entrepreneur that's my message to you on
how to handle chaos if you have any
questions about to comment on the bottom
and if you haven't subscribed to the
channel channel please do so thanks for
watching